welcome back everybody to the next
episode and beginner C++ series this is
episode 11 and now that we're getting
into multiple files and are compiling is
going to get notably more complicated
where we have type longer and longer
lines and we're also getting to the
point where we're going to probably
start adding flags to our compiling it's
gonna get a little tedious to keep
typing it in our terminal so I think
it's time I introduce you to a really
important thing that kind of goes along
with all programming and you see it
really in every language everywhere and
that's make files I'm really only gonna
go over the very basics of it here make
files our whole animal on their own
really you only need to know the basics
as a programmer and as far as you want
to go with it and have fun with it
that's up to you most people don't make
raw make files they have a program like
C make or Q make or something else that
builds a make file for you based on how
your projects setup but knowing how the
raw make files will work at least on a
basic level is pretty important they're
really critical for any field of science
really because you when you're crunching
big numbers and running big projects you
often want to do a lot of different
things and in specific orders and repeat
it and stuff like that so make files
allow you to do that it's just a little
file called a make file I'll go ahead
and make one okay so here's our here's
our file browser there and I'm gonna
just do the touch command and to make
file and make files our name just plain
old make file all lowercase you can
capitalize the first him and it's the
same so I think the standard is to
capitalize it but lowercase is just as
well and there we go it's just a plain
old file called make file and as its
name sort of suggested is for making
your program usually but really you can
use this to run anything and you're in
your command line or in your terminal
it's really all it does is it pushes
commands into your terminal and it
allows some logic for
doing different things based on either
what you type or on some conditional
stuff so real quick I just want to let
you know that there is lots of
references out there for it there are
lots of little tutorials on their own
and they're huge and I'm really not
gonna go any further than the very
basics so just FYI
it's open uh our make file and let's say
we just want to get our program
compiling with make file and how you
call a make file is you just go to the
directory and you type make it's
probably gonna it yeah it does
absolutely nothing says make no target
stop and make is a it's something you do
have to install for your terminal so you
if you're on like Linux or something you
want to do sudo sudo apt-get install
make or yeah I'm typing it all wrong but
you get the point
so you do need to install it and for
sick one the way you do that is you run
the cygwin installer executable and when
you get to the point where you're
installing parts of cygwin and you'll be
able to install it there all right well
let's let's do our thing so you can
define macros we're not gonna talk about
macros macros are basically variables
you can define up at the top but really
what you want to do is you want to give
a name of something like default or all
or something like that and this is what
will the very top one is what will run
if you just type playing old makin it'll
probably do nothing well I need to save
it so this is the name of it just you
can do make and it says nothing to be
done for default because yeah I haven't
done anything here but you can have
other ones like you can name them
whatever different things you can target
so you can do you could push different
commands you could save different
commands so by default just right okay
to the right of this colon here is the
thing it depends on so it's gonna check
for these files being built and usually
you want some sort of
well will not get into that too much but
often you want to check if something
exists and if it exists then you do a
certain thing so that's that's what this
is for but it's basically what it's to
the right of this is basically what it
looks for to exist and it checks if they
exist or not so often you'll see like if
you're building objects you're building
like a main dot object and maybe a a
calque gato object it'll look for those
to exist and if they already exist and
hit all then you'll have a target like
this down here and if it doesn't already
exist
well it'll look at this one down here
and check its dependencies and you'll
have something like this and it looks at
the time stamps so and it remembers
those so if you do something like this
and you're in your building these
objects separately which were not at
this moment I'm just kind of showing you
a quick example
it'll look at this it'll see if main dot
cpp has been updated since last build
and if it has it'll rebuild or it'll run
the command under here and you use use
tabs so it'd be like main and - oh to
toe the build so you'll see something
like this and there are fancier ways of
doing this but I don't want to make it
too complicated ok so you return you
return down a line and you tab over if
these are spaces right here if it ends
up your if your editor ends up putting
in spaces it's not gonna work it's gonna
throw a weird error and this down below
is what it runs in the command line if
this has been updated so if you've got a
bunch of objects you're building this
can be really handy because it will only
build the ones that have been updated
and then it'll link them all together at
the end
so you'll see something like this so I
haven't really talked about this
separate objects we've just been
compiling all our executables on the one
and just turning it into one but in
bigger projects the standard is to
compile each CVP individually turn it
into its own object and then link them
together so what this would do if you
just type plain old make is it would
look for remained Auto if main Auto
doesn't exist it'll go down here well
actually I think it checks no matter
what if it goes down here and if main up
CVP has been updated since the last
build then it knows it needs to rebuild
it and we'll run this and then it goes
to the next one and does the same thing
goes down here this needs updated and
then rebuilds it it also it also checks
for the existence if these don't exist
it just file runs it if they do exist
checks the time stamp on the cpp and
sees of these bills so this is so once
you build up a chain of these you can
you can basically just type plain old
make and it'll handle all the logic of
what you need to rebuild and it can save
you a lot of build time is rather than
building everything you can only build
the ones that were updated hope that
makes sense
clean cleaning is a pretty typical thing
to have to don't really need that one
don't really need that one and usually
what clean is is just a remove all your
previous object so it just just reset
your project so you'll set a little
Linux command there to delete your
objects and delete your executable but
we are keeping this so basic that we're
not even going to do that stuff but
that's will do this on part two I just
want to introduce you to that because
that's pretty critical for its flow all
we really have is an object we have one
a exe right so we don't really need to
do anything here we're just gonna flat
out compile it every time we're not
gonna check any logic that'll keep it as
simple as it gets
so we're gonna compile main dot cpp and
we're also compiling calculator piling
this class
and we have a what else do we have we
have helpers let's take a look at
helpers it's gonna we know what actually
go in there as you look at it and that's
just the most basic command on when we
were running last time so when we type
plain old make it'll run this and you
see it'll just build our program and
there we go let me know if you have any
questions and I will see you in the next
video thank you for watching keep on
coding guys remember believe in
yourselves don't get too involved in the
crazy world just you know stick to your
craft be happy and support the people
around you take it easy